are your personal interactions with
white people worse than ever yeah so if
you've turned on the news or even
glanced at social media over the last
few years you'd probably be under the
impression that race relations
particularly between white and black
Americans is at an all-time low the race
Wars are on the way if you will because
you have black people speak on behalf of
black people white people speak on
behalf of white people black people
telling white people white people
apologizing to black people but you
don't often see black people and white
people just talking is this reflective
of our real world experiences I think
you may be surprised with what I found
when I actually went out and did
something crazy talked with people this
is black and white on the gray
[Music]
issues first question I guess to you is
what would you say race relations are
like in the states right now how where
do you think they are I think it's
almost even man whereas what I mean when
I say even like okay you know there's
still some work to be done sure but
there's not as much work that needs to
be done because when you think about
race relations right now today yeah you
know what I'm saying everybody is
basically communicating with each other
everybody is doing their thing together
you know what I'm saying they're linking
up on different fronts they just taking
care of their business you know what I'm
saying now you got some people that are
dummies who
really don't you can say
want to get with the program mhm yeah
and you got you know what I'm saying
because you it's a lot of things going
on in the world man yeah well you're
also going to have individual racist
right people who are racist but it
sounds to me like you're saying you
think that they're better now than they
were before that they're no I'm saying
times are better yeah because if you
think if you go back to emit till people
like that oh yeah you know what I'm
saying the times then versus the times
now yeah if you come to deep element
yeah and you going to see then we kind
of ended up with more of that right
until then me too came out and there
were a bunch of people being falsely
accused but on the same but on the same
token what I'm saying like you saying
race relations and issues when every
when I come the Deep building that's all
I see is everybody's you know just like
connected with each other well that's
what I see in real life but I mean in
the media you know in the media often
times things are stoked where they make
it seem like it's worse I mean you know
uh no you don't think so no well that's
a good thing I really think that like
the media function is like on some on a
scale bigger than what people think mhm
you know what I'm saying and I think
that like I really believe that they
that today how the media operate it
can't operate with that basic regular
stuff that it used to operate with right
so they have to go like deep covered
right you know what I'm saying and
really get the good juice good stuff you
know what I'm saying yeah so you think
media has an interest in controversy and
making race relations seem worse than
they are in real life most definitely
yeah most definitely that's what I find
too I find that my interactions you know
having been raised in a church where was
mixed you know a lot of black people in
church and being a comic you know being
around a lot of guys my interactions are
very different from what you see in the
media as far as me say this here man
yeah see like when you start putting
labels on things that's when things get
messed up right right so like bam if we
all American right we all American right
so like if I go to a hospital and I need
a blood transfusion right I can't say
don't put that white blood in me or that
mesan blood you feel me I got a septic
that they going to give me I hope it you
know what I'm saying work that's a good
analogy oh good on God so like I think
that every ever since people put
analogies on that's when it got messed
up yeah because now you can you you can
view this as something different right
that's a black thing that's a white
thing he's black he's white but you
know what I'm saying what about the
American culture yeah so do you the
great Melting Pot are you proud to be
American right yeah man you so you think
it's a great country flaws but proud to
be American yeah here yeah yeah what do
you and that that's been my you know
experience with both white and black
Americans what do you think about you
know obviously this happened deep Elm
like black lives matter uh I think all I
think all lives matter oh shoot but I
think that people but if I say that you
know I'm a white supremacist right they
said you can't say it was a racist term
listen I think this what I think that
all people do I think all people use the
race issue as a platform for some
sometimes you know what I'm
saying yeah sometimes they let alcohol
things of that nature you know
understand me wiring them up to say some
that they really don't mean mean
right you you know what I'm saying
trying to catch someone you know what
I'm saying No it's it's kind of like
crazy like say like you might be with
with with some of your white Partners y
out drinking so bam and and and and and
y'all have some words with someone and
then heard it is boom
right you know what I'm saying yeah you
know I'm not going to say it cuz if I
said I'm going to have a bunch of fists
coming down people that do that you have
people that do that under the influence
and then the next day regret that they
did something like that okay so you're
saying someone could say that in a
moment of anger and not be a racist just
be mad most definitely like if you get
mad or something you know and you're
with a friend and you say I hate or like
when you're a kid you say Dad I hate you
you don't really hate them you're like
ah we got into a fight so someone could
just say something that doesn't mean
they're racist it means they had a
moment of weakness and anger yeah no I
agree and then we judge people at their
worst moment and that's that's really
messed up everybody going to be judged
yep yep y I really appreciate the
opportunity well let me let me ask I
appreciate it too man I actually think
your point of view is refreshing that
people should hear this because a lot of
people out there I will tell you this a
lot of white people out there are scared
to have conversations they're scared
because they're scared a lot of white
people no a lot of white people are man
because they're afraid of being called
the racist if I'm going tell you it's
the ones that ain't got no business
going on bro you know what I'm saying
that's scary because if you got some
business going on man yeah money don't
have color bro right you feel me so you
got to deal with everybody so you have
to have relationships with different
different types of people bro you know
what I'm saying out so I got to learn
how so that mean that you understand me
as an American in America I got to be
like uh switching up to be a Mexican to
be able to talk to all cultures man but
we just one culture man we just need to
throw all those Hispanics and all that
I ain't saying forget about your
history or nothing like that I'm just
saying we got a history here yeah not be
colorblind but we have more in common
than we have as different but we also
need to unify on different fronts you
understand me and get all these
different you understand me ideologies
and social programs and all this jump
that's jumping off get that man get move
that out the way man does it live life
man if you if you do something take your
lit yeah take responsibility for it I
will all the time no and I appreciate
that's one thing that I appreciate is
the accountability culture what you're
talking about nowadays you got a lot of
people out here they not taking
accountability no you think that's the
big problem on all fronts I think so I
agree see like if you see if you got one
finger point at you you got one point
back too cuz your thumb point back at
you that'd be a white ass finger too
he's as white as they gu that's rushing
this dude right here he needs some
something like like
he's he's got SPF ozone layer on right
now yeah man let me ask you a couple so
these are like some issues that you know
you hear about in the media and they
turn it into a racial issue and I I
don't think it is right do you think uh
for example voting to have
identification just any kind of ID does
that make sense to you you think you
should have ID to vote I think the only
way you should have ID or need ID is if
there is a census see if there's a
sensus that mean that you done counter
everybody so you know how many people
live in the county right right so bam so
if this person if we got say 50,000 in
the county then you know uh you got to
have percent you got to have ID so now
your ID validates your vote right you
know what I'm saying yeah yeah that's
exactly yeah I think we agree on that
one um right now a big cultural issue
going on uh you know like biological men
the trans men competing in women's
sports hey I don't say man I don't think
that should be done I think that if a
dude was if he born a dude no matter
what his sexual sexuality
I think that he still in the in in the
eyes of man and God going to remain a
dude so he can cut his penis off he can
you know what I'm saying inflate his
chest he can put and his butt it's going
to it's still a dude I don't know what
he does with his butt I don't think
that's part of the procedure he still he
still got testosterone man yeah or at
least he did no that's a big ISS well
here what do do you think it's crazy
though that what you just said and I
agree with you could be labeled hate
speech right cuz now they'll say oh
you're transphobic no no no no because
look see this what see this what people
don't understand like see like like what
they have made homosexuality a mental
disease man you know what I'm saying you
can be put on psych medication to be a
homosexual yeah or for being you know
just because you homosexual you're
saying now they've like enabled it with
the sports stuff where it's like yeah
you can't have dudes no no I'm talking
about they have a psych term yeah you
know what I'm saying like like like like
say this dude is homosexual you go in
the D DSM new book and look up a
diagnosis up under homosexuality yeah
well they change it though like with
trans so that did you know that they
changed it where it used to be uh body
dysmorphia was if you were you know
claiming you a transgender they said it
was a disorder of someone who thought
they were you know transgender but now
they changed it to say oh no no you are
actually a woman it's a symptom of the
fact that you're not you're born in the
wrong VI can't be a woman no yeah that's
just that's just that's just a lot of
people just having too many ideas in
their head man and then like people take
things too literal sometimes man you
know what I'm saying like religion all
that stuff man you know I think that at
the end of the day man if if uh if you
go through your problems and live your
problems and if if you happy with what
you got going on then everything's great
with you we're all Americans right and
you believe in personal accountability
all lives matter people need to stop
making it all about race that's right
and no snitching yeah know I agree hey
that's one thing I do appreciate about
the black community for sure I've had
few of these guys are snitches I'm not
sure that they're not hey Bri thanks
man oh man I appreciate it man that was
refreshing
[Music]
thanks Jah Josiah nice to meet you
Josiah um here let me grab cuz last time
I was doing an interview there and they
opened the door and it hit us so I'm an
idiot so where's the best place for us
to
pee how would you sort of characterize
or how do you view like race relations
in the United States right now how do
you see it um I do believe a lot of it
is um an agenda so again I I look at the
things from like a a micro level like
the things that they are portraying and
projecting right now I think that is to
distract people from um what's what's
really important you know what I'm
saying so when I look at the race issues
and I believe that's what you're talking
about right now there's a racial divide
that's what the media port how they
portray yeah um I don't necessarily
believe that I I'm a light-skinned
person myself so if you know what that
means mean not compared to these
guys unless you're translucent yeah um
I'm uh I'm black and white I mean so
I've definitely experienced both sides
of the spectrum when it comes to things
like that so I lived in a place like
Louisiana which was very Southern right
and if you know the history of Louisiana
like it's um I guess it was a very
racial place but um my growing up there
in high school I experienced a lot more
racism from the black people than from
the white people and that's that's to
say yeah
um and then when I like what kind of
what kind of racism would you experience
from black people I would say I would
say like when you talk about like
discrimination against a group that's
what I'm saying I I feel that I was
discriminated towards because of lighter
skin now the white people in the school
I wouldn't say that there was really any
conflict um with them between me and
that's what I feel like it is more um
what the media wants to do and I what I
feel like a lot of even black people are
um struggling with is believing uh the
media what not that's surprising as a as
a not half a completely white person
obviously I mean I was Raising canid I'm
very very white um we're always told and
especially with Barack Obama that oh
biracial people are always treated like
they're black right that's what you hear
in the media and that wasn't your
experience yeah definitely not um I I
don't believe that that's an experience
for most and I believe that uh America
um a lot of people have a a victim
mentality and they don't really ever
search Truth for themselves and um they
just get fed a lot of things and a lot
of truth so yeah that's what I struggle
with a lot um especially a place like
Dallas it's a Melting Pot you know I
mean so um it's it's it's nice to live
in a place like this but then you also
see um a lot of uh people just being
distracted by all that's going around
them and never really um searching Truth
uh for themsel and that's what what
makes me sad you know I mean um I'm a
believer I'm a Christian um I believe in
the word of God I believe in Jesus so
when I see people being deceived by
these these things that they're
portraying to be big and then actually
just distracting them from deeper truth
then I I get pretty frustrated by that
so man it's refreshing to hear because
you're saying I would I would agree with
pretty much everything you just said
right but and I think this is an issue
too like I obviously think racism exists
to some degree there are individual
racist like you've experienced it um
white people are very of what you just
said white people would be afraid to say
because they be afraid to be accused of
being racist right that is a fear right
now which I will tell you creates a
divide like if they when black lives
matter happened right we just talked
about or three guys I said man I think
all lives matter and I said now white
people were called supremacists if they
said that so they go I'm just not going
to voice an opinion that creates more
distance do you do you sense that a
little bit where maybe white people are
kind of pulling back because they're
afraid of being a it's a Witch Hunt that
everything is racist if they express the
exact same opinions you just did most
white people in you that's that's 100%
in common yeah and that's what I would
have to say that there needs to instead
of starting a group that is labeled
black lives matter which again like when
so I see a lot on of of the media right
of like when like um somebody will post
like oh this strong black woman and then
like and that happens by the black
community where they continue to
describe themselves and kind of uh
belittle themselves by their skin color
that like okay that's what's important
by me about me I mean what I'm saying
and I don't think that's what's
important about anybody and even when it
goes into the and I this might be a
little bit off topic but when you go
into the gay community or the trans
Community it's funny to me on topic
whole identity is wrapped in their
sexuality you know what I'm saying so
and I I just see like that's a very sad
Life to Live um for anybody and even as
like let's say I walked around here a
light-skinned and I started um or an uh
African-American you know what I mean I
I walked around here and I made my whole
life just about my skin color and uh
praising that and lifting that up um I
just think that that's the biggest waste
of time and a distraction that I think
the media tries to push and I think the
the best thing they could do is continue
to keep tension between racial groups
when there really shouldn't be any um
again in my life I haven't came across
anybody um and when they talk about like
Sy systemic racism um that hasn't been
my experience with life at all so I
think that people really need to look
into their own life experiences and not
take the life experiences of certain
people um and then claim that as their
own just because it's from their same
racial group so I think that was very
well said let me let me ask you one kind
of question in closing why do you think
what you just said um by way it's a
mixed group they're white but a mixed
group of people here we have you know we
have Russian we have sometimes black
people don't realize like not all white
people are the same but everyone would
agree with what you just said it was
well spoken why do you think what you
just said is not something that is ever
echoed as representative of the black
community in the media meeing with CNN
places like that what you've just said
you don't hear as a voice in the black
community um I think that the people who
do try to speak up in that sense um do
get shut down and get portrayed as
they're crazy or they're psycho or
they're mentally ill for having strong
opinions and that's what frustrates me
about the media is that like um and and
it's true that people even on Instagram
you see stuff that is calling out like
liberal groups of people um it it says
sensitive uh uh false content you know
what I mean so you see stuff getting
censored like that and it's like then
you you see that already there's an
agenda that um that they don't they
don't want um truth to be made known so
that's what I say I think it goes a lot
deeper than just um um the conversation
of black and white or even what these
people are doing I think that there's a
much deeper agenda and I think it goes
all the the way down to um uh that the
devil has a plan for this world um and
but God also has one too and that's for
Jesus to be made known I would I would
certainly agree with you man and here's
the thing would it surprise you that
like we've spoken with a lot of people a
lot of black men today MH and what
you're saying is not uncommon like there
are a lot of dudes who think the same
way um but people don't talk like we
have a lot more in common than separates
us and uh I agree man it's a symptom of
the heart it's not a symptom of the
melanin level
yeah I love that I love that yeah so I
mean I mean I appreciate uh what you
guys do you know I mean I would say that
conversations are very much needed I
love a lot of uh uh I love the work of
people who like to sit down and have
conversation and I think that
um we are starting to see a lot more
people rise up and and speak truth and
kind of get out of um it just starts
with talking man that's what it is it
just starts with talking with people not
listening to what other people are it's
like a game of telephone so what happens
with a lot of white people and black
people is like black black people think
this and then it goes van Jones goes
black people think that he goes black
people think this and the white people
like oh okay let me go tell other white
people black people think this and then
at the end we're like oh yeah all black
people are uh trans activist Communists
or whatever the hell it is and people
were like what that's not what I said I
said uh Apple like in
phone oh I'll just say hey man I
appreciate it man I really do thank you
be blessed man you guys as
well now before we move on to the next
conversation and Josiah was not a plant
I absolutely swear if you appreciate
these kinds of discussions hit the like
button comment below if any of this has
surprised you thus far or if you'd like
to see more of these and do consider
checking out the live Daily Show Monday
through Friday at 10:00 a.m. easn right
here on YouTube or preferably
Rumble
how would you sort of characterize race
relations in the United States today
between like white and black people
between white and blacks again depending
on where you are uh Society wise a lot
of times often times your ZIP code
determines your interaction yeah with so
for instance if you're from my NE of the
woods It's all where you from um I'm
actually from here from Dallas so okay
but the ZIP codes in doubt is dictator
determine right how often you interact
with someone so um for my profession
I'll say it for this way if I'm on a
certain side of town yeah and I'm
supposed to protect and serve right but
yet the same if you see me as this yeah
you clutch your purse or just you know
big Dominican black guy with tattoos mhm
or he's a Afraid on the other side of
time he like hey bro how you doing man
come on over right so it all depends on
where you're located and uh your
exposure pretty much so you think that
in certain areas of you think that the
white people like you said P white women
are are afraid of you no no actually um
not at all actually no um it uh it ought
I think that I have to as a person
speaking for me yeah I have to be a bit
more re receiving Hi how are you
pleasure yeah and then hey what's up how
you doing right that that interaction
because I have to be more than and do
you find that then the interaction is
usually positive if you do that I do
it's disarming it's somewhat disarming
yeah absolutely why do you think some
people might have that initial reaction
if you don't interact that way depending
on whatever their experiences have been
U for inst if it's you see the villain
on a TV show or on a movie Always if
it's the the guy that's putting his mask
down car jacket and if he looks like oh
dude no no I got to disagree if I have
to watch another Simply Safe commercial
where it's a white guy who kicks in the
door at 2: a.m. come on I have never
seen a commercial ever where a black d
criminal but they're smarter than that
they wouldn't do that it'd be the end of
the okay okay so we agree on that
they're always like it's always like
some guy some guy who looks like Gary
who's like there to like I'm here to Rob
your home like that's not what happens
yeah you know so but it's a I think
ideally if you put yourselves in an open
environment or if you're trying if
you're open to it if you go to a park
and it's not Highland Park or it's not
University Park but if it's just a park
go interact with the kids often time I
think that part of societ is actually
taught to us and this is my my own
perspective if you put a group of five
and sixy olds around in playground yeah
they could care less right what the
color of your skin is right or where
your ZIP code is or how much your 401k
is or whatever they could care less
right um they're just going to play
they're just going to show love they're
going to have fun and I think that as
adults as we as Society if we can get to
that place again to where it's hey man I
see I see a human yeah I see a person we
have more in common than separates us
probably in a lot of ways AG but you
know if you watch certainly if you watch
everything in the media things are
always categorized Often by race very
often now of course sex and gender um
and I've always found again like going
to church here in Texas like one I went
to in Carolton was very mixed it was
almost 5050 absolutely always had very
good interactions there was a disconnect
from hold a second on TV they're making
it seem like we're Worlds Apart those AR
my interactions on a daily basis
absolutely absolutely and even with
myself he gave you the dumb up or
something oh okay all right I don't know
what he's doing all right cool but um
just I mean in in a place such as that
you're supposed to be open welcome and
in hospitals and churches everybody's
supposed to be right open to you're
welcome hey come on in yeah and I think
that as Society we shouldn't get too far
from that in which we
couldn't find a place of hey man I just
want to reach you yeah I want to know
you what what is it about you well one
thing I'll say cuz you you talk about
sort of your interactions that maybe
some people might clutch their purse
right or have these sort of precon
happen to me I'm like man if anything
happened by law I'd have to protect you
I'm not I'm not threat well and I think
for sure there are some people who have
those preconceived notions right and
black people are probably sometimes like
you're saying you have you have to go
out of your way because you're concerned
of them thinking maybe you're let's say
you're violent on the flip side you have
white people often now they're very
afraid of interacting with black people
because they're afraid of being accused
of being racist that's a fear that a lot
of white people have now okay that I
think maybe sometimes black people don't
well we all have our kind of concerns
cuz that that white woman may have she
may have been mugged you know what I
mean she may have had a life like you
said a life experience
and wants to avoid it and if we don't
talk it just gets worse we just separate
more and more i' I've had in my
experiences as well and I also have a u
um uh young lady that I was in a
relationship she's Caucasian we have a
beautiful tri-racial baby together and
her experience and a lot of the things
that I've exposed her to about my world
before she would ever have known because
they don't teach that in school they
don't teach certain aspects of culture
right on that side of the world yeah
kind of from being from whites Barrow or
pots bar they don't teach yeah what
island it has white in the
name that's a town yeah there's also
White Settlement so I came from Canada
I'm like how the hell do you name the
town this like how you get away with it
I know I get it I get it I have nothing
to do that was years
before just the exposure itself and and
now it's more than a just uh it's more
than well hey I understand him it's I'm
receptive to him right okay he's not bad
his family isn't bad they're not bad
they're loving just like everyone else
what do you um what do you think kind of
especially here in deep Elm what would
you say the results were afterwards of
since you're saying we don't want to
just label people by race but like you
know black lives matter and there was
there's a lot of Fallout from that um
how would you classify that now would
you say it was good for relations across
the country I think the topic itself was
specific for that not that any not that
got not that anything that no no life
matter everyone lives matter in my
opinion even from my aspect from my side
looking and I'll Stand in the front of
the line and I'm the other guy that
they're saying hey F you guys cuz you're
a cop you know they're saying F you guys
but wait right hey dude my life don't
matter you're just mad at me because of
the uniform it's like working at any
other place waterburger or Walmart it's
my uni it's who I am but it doesn't
dictate right yeah I don't know what it
was like here for you but um you know my
dad over there he was born and raised in
Detroit in bad area of Detroit and the
people had at worst there the worst were
were black cops in Detroit they would
have to go home and unmarked cars when
the riots were happening because a lot
of them were seen as you know they would
say Uncle Tom's and they were they were
they were threatened they were targeted
Uncle Tom but I know well that's not
even no it's a good point it's like
using something you're like I don't
think you know what you're saying you
don't read a book read read it's not a
that would be a good start but um yeah
no that would be a good start but yeah
Black Ops in Detroit I don't know how
what but it was really really bad um and
I think that all lives matter in itself
but in particular on that time frame
yeah that's what we were saying Hey
listen whoa hold up yeah dude is
reaching for his wallet let him get his
wallet right and that's saying from both
sides of the fence for myself right hey
man let him get his wallet so what you
just said and you just touched I just
said a guy was talking he said the exact
same thing that you just said right
everybody's lives matter all lives
matter now here's a question that I
would have and if you I I know I don't
have unlimited time but you know that
was something that a lot of people said
so white people say look I think all
that matter and they were called racists
or white supremacists if they said
exactly what you just said that's
ignorance that's ignorance and but can
you see how that makes white people
afraid to even voice an opinion that's
the same as yours in other words we
share the opinion but I'm telling you
just like you're saying a lot of but it
wasn't about it's it's basically okay
this is our this is where we're standing
right stand with me I get it I'm not
saying yours doesn't but we're all
unified saying hey these these lives
matter this specific person this
specific group this specific people
their lives matter sure so it wasn't
necessarily oh you're racist because
you're saying all lives matter we're not
talking about that other part right now
we're just talking about this B yeah so
let's focus and fix and help here yeah
but like you just said though right
that's not you just said that all lives
do matter everyone's lives and there are
a lot of there are a lot of white people
come from poor areas too right who have
struggles and they were saying well hey
we need to fix this and if you think the
system is rigged because it's racist and
I by the way I think the justice system
has a lot of problems I think that if
you just see it as a white and black
thing you're going to miss a lot of the
problems right and so saying if we need
to fix this system we can't just
approach it from a racial angle that all
lives matter that Justice matters period
and it's not being done then you can get
to the solution but I'm telling you that
a lot of white people were scared
obviously because crime obviously went
up here you know had to board up their
businesses and they were afraid to voice
their opinion or reach out like now and
just talk to people because they're
afraid of being called a racist that's
something that's internal with you cuz I
never said hey not no not not you but
I'm say the media labeled everyone that
way yeah people or black people as a
culture they never said hey don't come
talk me you just automatically shut up
and well I can't get why I didn't tell
you didn't have it no nobody told you
you couldn't I want to hear you I want
to be I want to know what you're
thinking cuz if I can't get it if I
don't know what's in your head I can't
hear out of your heart you have Jesus is
risen on your chest the Bible says out
of the abundance of the heart the mouth
is going to speak right so whatever your
mouth say that was in your heart right
so let me know what's in your heart yeah
and that's exactly the point is like
you're saying if they don't reach out
it's usually white people using it as a
weapon calling other white people racist
and then they shut down and then this
divide gets created absolutely um let me
ask something like this like these are
some hot button issues right now all
right all right let me ask you uh uh
right now big issue for example I think
we probably share a lot in common here
okay black and white people across the
board uh trans men competing biological
men and women's sports that's where do
you line up on that I don't have an
opinion you don't have an opinion I
don't all right I just I genuinely don't
have an OP okay let me ask you this uh
the idea of you know vote because you're
you said you enforced the law I don't
want to you have to keep SEC uh people
vote right you voter ident just any kind
of identification I think that's
something like that's something that's
been turned into a racial issue which
doesn't seem like it should be um I
think it's more difficult for certain
people to get yeah the opportunity and
even if you've already paid your this is
my take if you already paid your debt to
society you've already done what you've
had to do why can't you at this point
you can't you vote yeah why can't you
vote well just to make sure that you're
the guy or girl voting well even even
still who often says hey my name is John
Jacob J goer Smith his name is my name
or I'm just hey man my name is Eric and
dude was from Whitesboro by the way oh
my gosh triin oh my God no but I don't I
I think that everybody should have a
voice no matter who you are what side of
the fence you're on in the middle far on
the right far on the left what's your
voice yeah speak your peace all right
man and you know that's what we're
trying to do and I think I think it's a
lot more productive than what you hear
in the media people sitting around it's
just absolutely it ain't so bad it ain't
so bad calm down you heard it from him
breathe it ain't so bad we want to do it
together everybody Does It Better
Together thanks man I appreciate you
taking the time man that was really
really productive God
[Music]
bless Jord my brother's name is Jordan
I'm stepen nice to meet you man nice to
meet how would you classify or like
characterize you know where we are in a
as a country right now uh racially
between you know black white not in a
good spot not in a good spot no no you
think it's worse yeah so uh like why
would you say that worse than when or
why I mean it's
just
um uh I don't know what the root cuse of
it is it's just we're not in a good spot
it's just yeah I mean you look at events
I mean even most recently it happened
this weekend it's like it just shows
where it's kind of like going to race
fors it's just different different times
and that's but and this is kind of what
I'm is you see that in the media right a
lot but you know being a comedian having
spent a lot of time around black Comics
or a lot of black people just
disproportionately in comedy and then
I've gone to churches that are very
mixed my interactions on a personal
level are very positive uh lifelong
relationships but if you watch the media
you're going to hear about the race Wars
and the division do you think there's
maybe that are your personal
interactions with white people worse
than ever yeah oh really yeah like what
what kind of stuff they do I mean I have
all kind you have all kinds of stuff you
have the people that think susceptable
to touch your hair um like you're a dog
you have the people that you know know I
mean it's all kinds of different things
that just happen where it's just like
okay yeah this isn't that's not
acceptable by no State former fashion so
I don't know why we're doing this that
seems like a jump though from that to
race war well I mean it's like I'm
trying to think of some other things
that have happened I've been called
names by people yeah I've been like it's
been all kinds of like random things
you've been not welcome inside of places
before it's all kinds of like it just
depends on like where you're at um where
were are you from Dallas here originally
uh what area specifically uh Mansville
oh okay uh I'm trying Mansfield where
where is that uh by for worth oh okay oh
yeah it's a nice area so uh what was it
like being raised like what would you
how would you classify your neighborhood
how would you sort of describe it u i
mean mansvi is a primarily like white
area yeah um Suburban America M uh
actuallyy was one of like the last
school districts in the country to
desegregate right um so I mean yeah it's
you know they have their problems I
didn't really deal with much there I
really was exposed to stuff I was an
adult right but it was mostly white
Suburban so you'd think you'd be exposed
to those people when so you're saying
when you were young they was mostly
decent yeah the interactions mhm okay um
what do you think about you know
bringing that up uh this is a white guys
perspective the segregation coming back
in in colleges and black only spaces
right you mentioned to be desegregated
we're moving back toward that under
different guys where do you line up on
that you think that's productive what do
you mean to have black only spaces
either in high schools or colleges right
to label those things seems to me as an
ignorant white guy it's kind of like
segregating again I could see that I
think it's everybody needs their safe
space to where they can go be their
authentic self where they can you know
really like Vibe with other people that
are you know like them um I'm not saying
like it should be like oh white only or
black only locations or slots or stuff
but like I mean if you see black people
Gather in certain places like okay no me
those are policies like those are actual
policies like at schools now where
they'll have black only spaces um which
doesn't seem like that's really school
is that we had it start with mizou right
and there have been a few others in the
I mean we just had the affirmative
action ruling you know where they said
no okay uh because Asians were sort of
suffering at the hands of Harvard and
brown where do you line up on that do
you think that it's uh do you think that
that's an issue that anyone who would
say you know what I don't think that
categorizing people accepting them by
race even if you disagree with them does
that make that person a racist who
thinks affirmative action is maybe not
the best you don't agree at affirmative
action or you're racist
yeah I wouldn't say you're racist but I
mean you should probably look at history
to see like hey what why do we have
affirmative accident and then what's the
importance of it I mean whenever you got
to realize like people tell I've been
hired at jobs before cuz they told me
I'm black right that's not acceptable so
it's like you know it'ss used in some
that's sometimes use in good ways
sometimes used in bad ways moments like
that it's like okay cool I rather you
look at like my qualification see like
hey what is it that I do right and see
like okay great you're the best
candidate for this versus like okay cool
you got it cuz you're black okay um so I
mean it really just it just depends
overall so it sounds like you're saying
that maybe be of AC not a very not a
great thing if someone's just hiring you
because of your
race I think that's all it does there is
nothing else about it it's hiring people
based on their race right and you're and
and honestly that's got to be a terrible
feeling if you're like well I feel like
I've accomplished a lot I rather look at
my accomplishments than just say I'm
hiring you because you're black that
seems racist to me well I mean the part
of the thing is like I don't know white
like no offense you I don't know white
people understand this but it's like
black people just get lived over all the
time where it's like it doesn't matter
what our accomplishments are if you look
at me on a piece of paper and a white
person on a piece of paper it's going to
be two different experiences okay I've
seen it firsthand in Corporate America
I've seen it firsthand in University as
well so this is but this is okay so this
is one thing that I think maybe we can
can you maybe come to a place of with
white people here let's say I'm a white
business owner okay you just voiced uh
displeasure and I understand with
someone not hiring you you know looking
at two rums because they don't
necessarily know okay but then you also
said that it was kind of crappy that
someone hired you because you're black m
what's a white business owner to do MH I
mean here's the thing it should it
shouldn't have to be something that's a
policy that's there it should just be
something that you're doing because it's
the right thing to do it shouldn't be
like the thing of okay cool I know I
need to increase my diversity numbers
cuz that's normally what it is I need to
increase my diversity numbers and then
from there then we're going to hire
black people so it's like no that's just
the right thing to do mirror your
customers is the right thing to do to
hire based on race or just or to hire
based on right hire diversity have a
diverse work course but what if they're
not the best person then hey you you can
find people if beon like they say if
Beyonce can find 14 black tonus I'm sure
you can find one black person to join
your team it's not that hard but
somewhere there's likely somewhere
there's likely a Japanese American bonus
who got screwed out of a job was very
good at it just like Harvard and brown
right who had higher SAT scores which is
fine I mean it's one of those things
it's just are they racist I mean it's
one of those things where you know what
you want so it's like okay if you know
what you want then like but what if you
don't want it what if you just want the
best Trump bonus then do what you have
to do okay no I so it sounds like we
would find common ground and then hire
the best person and do what you want and
it shouldn't be policy to force on
someone because that doesn't turn
someone not racist like a Clansman is
not going to hire black people because
of affirmative action no matter what mhm
right but maybe someone else might hire
you just because you're black and that's
a crappy feeling as opposed to your
accomplishments yeah okay no I think
that that makes sense I was trying to
trying to make sure that we understand
where we line up and safe spaces we were
talking about uh that that could apply
like black white gay straight I would
assume that that would also be kind of
you know as far as identity intersect
all that those would be things that
you're talking about y yeah all right no
I appreciate I'm glad we had this
conversation man J I know you I know you
got gotta boy it's like I'm sweating
like a stuck pig here so it's all good
so no I appreciate you taking the time
problem thanks
bro well there you have it we'll
continue to test my hypothesis that the
narrative the mainstream media is so
desperately trying to force down your
throats may not be reflective of what
you experience in the real world and hey
just look at how much can be
accomplished by actually talking with
people grab your neighbor pick the
brains ask them the real questions that
you might have been afraid to and you
might be surprised with the answers and
please listen you may find that you have
a lot more in common with your fellow
American black or white then you think
if you want more of these hit like
comment below this has been black and
white on the gray issues if you like
this video subscribe and consider
joining us for our next installment of
this series where things get a little
spicy to rewind and you'll be able to
see the behavior that you have exhibited
here and not myself and you can watch it
you can rewind it that's what you think
of black
women remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at lwith c.com
mugclub gain access to an unrivaled
catalog of unapologetic and entertaining
creators including the Hodge twins Nick
depalo Brian Ken and of course Alex
Jones all that and everything you see
today is entirely funded by viewers like
you for $89 annually join the fight at
Lou withth credit.com mugclub
today